(techno sound)
(light instrumental music)
- [Announcer] We are the paradoxical aid.
Bipedal, naked, large brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable.
Yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(light instrumental music)
(upbeat instrumental music)
- Okay, well it's a great honor to be here
and I thank the organizers
Nick and Ajit for inviting me
and also all of you for coming.
So I would like to start
by showing you a video clip
of something that we filmed last summer
in Gorongosa National Park in Mozambique.
So Gorongosa's an amazing
biodiversity hotspot
and we have here what looks like a fairly,
kind of peaceful scene.
So we have a troupe of
baboons resting and feeding.
We've got some warthogs walking around.
We've got some waterbuck
grazing and so on.
So it's all quite idyllic.
But, of course, nature's rarely idyllic
and if you look more closely
you can see that this guy
here in the middle is
quite busy doing something.
And then if we zoom in,
which we will in a second,
we'll see that he has hunted
and he's now eating a
young antelope, a reedbuck.
But, unlike a lion with a killer bite,
this baboon is eating the
antelope while it's still alive.
Which you could argue is
not particularly sensible
given that it means that
the antelope still has
a chance to escape, which
as you'll see in a second,
it's still very much
trying to do at this point.
So for us, I think this really is quite a
sort of gruesome scene,
but at the same time,
it does raise some very
interesting questions that we can
ask about what might be going
on in that baboon's head.
And some of those questions
actually hark back
to what Nick was talking
about in his introduction.
So for example, does this baboon know
that the antelope is still alive?
Does the baboon know that
the fact that the antelope
is moving is a sign that it's still alive?
Does the baboon know that
it can kill the antelope?
And does it know what it needs
to do to kill the antelope?
And that once it has killed it,
the antelope will remain dead?
Does the baboon know that
it itself will die one day
and so will all other baboons
and will other antelopes and so on?
And then finally, you might
have noticed in that video,
the antelope's mother
standing to one side.
So another question could be, I think,
will the antelope's mother
grieve for her calf?
So I can't promise to
be able to answer most
or even any of these questions,
but what I will try to do in this talk
is to fist survey what kinds of responses
have been recorded among non-human animals
to dead individuals and what
these responses might tell us
about the kind of underlying
death related concepts in these animals.
And then at the end I will
also briefly consider grief
specifically as well as what implications
a better understanding of these phenomena
might have for animal welfare.
So, on this graphical
summary what I tried to do
was to put together, to
give you an idea basically
of the orders of mammals,
so the taxonomic orders
of mammals from which we have published
scientific reports on responses to death.
And I think one of the
things that quickly pops out
is that these reports cover
quite a broad taxonomic spread,
although some orders are represented
by just one or a few species.
And that of course
doesn't mean that mammals
in other orders don't respond to the dead.
It's just that we don't
have, yet have good
kind of published reports on them.
So, for example, we don't
really know a great deal
about how bats or (mumbles)
or kangaroos respond to the dead.
Although for at least some of
these kind of missing pieces,
we do have some anecdotal
evidence that exists.
Just not scientifically published yet.
So we'll come back to this figure later
when we look at what
specific ways there are
of animals' responses or
animals' treatment of the dead.
But first what I want to do now
is to quickly tell you
about three chimpanzee
case reports that we observed
at our field research site
which is coordinated by Kyoto University
and which is located in
Bossou in Guinea West Africa.
And they're each kind of
incredibly striking cases I think.
Things you see, once you see them,
you don't easily forget them.
All three cases involved young
individuals, young infants,
so Jokro, Jimato and
Veve, each of whom died
of a suspected respiratory illness
before they turned three years old.
And these dead infants,
they weren't abandoned
by their mothers, but they
continued to be carried
and to be looked after, to
be groomed and protected
much like live animals at this age
would be by their mothers.
And over the course of the carrying,
all three infants mummified
and the length of the carrying
was really extraordinary.
So in the first case,
carrying continued for more than 27 days.
In the second case, for 68 days.
And then in the third case, for 19 days.
And it's extraordinary for many reasons,
but one of the reasons is
that this length of carrying,
really amazing because the
infants have to be carried
in ways that no live infant ever is
because they could no
longer hold on their mother
and they could no longer cling,
so they really encumbered their mothers,
they had to be carried in unusual ways.
So for example, between,
sorry, by grasping a limb
between the neck and the shoulder
which is what you see in these images here
when the mothers were walking.
Or by climbing and then,
sorry, when climbing,
holding the body between
the thigh and the belly,
the so-called thigh
pocket in the chimpanzee,
that's what you see in this image.
Or even by dangling just by the foot
when resting in the trees.
And the mothers also
continued to groom the bodies
and they swatted flies from them.
You're seeing that in that video.
And the grooming in particular,
I think you can interpret
in different ways I guess.
So you could for example,
argue that the mothers,
these mothers don't know
that their infants are dead.
And they continue to treat them as live.
Or that they do know that
the infants are not live,
not alive, but they choose
to keep them clean anyway.
And then group-mates other than the mother
also showed a lot of
interest in the bodies.
So we saw a number of different responses
from these individuals.
They ranged from investigatory behaviors
like smelling and touching and inspecting
or lifting limbs and dropping them
to dragging and pulling and
playing with the corpses.
But also to caretaking and attendance.
So this, for example, here is
this dead infant's grandmother
who sat by the corpse while
the mother was off feeding.
And she groomed it and
she swatted flies from it.
And the mothers were
generally quite tolerant
to these behaviors even if it meant
relinquishing possession
of the corpses temporarily.
So you this one particular mother here
and there's the corpse left behind
and this is a juvenile that
comes in quite cautiously,
picks up the corpse and carries it off.
And you see the mother
initially, she turns around
and she sort of gets
up as if she was making
to go to get the corpse
back, but eventually she just
sort of lets the juvenile
run off with it and play.
And again this is not to
dissimilar to what a live infant
of this age would be allowed to do.
Two-year-olds do still travel
with the mother at all times.
But when the group is
stationary the mothers do allow
these infants to wander off
and play with others in the group.
And then interestingly
or maybe importantly,
we never saw any aggression
being directed towards the corpses.
Although in one case, this is the one case
when an adult male used
one of these bodies
in a display during a fight.
So this was at the point when the body
had already completely mummified.
But even here I think
this seemed like rather
kind of gentle handling of the corpse.
He's not tearing it to pieces,
he's not sort of flinging it around,
but actually sort of quite softly
just pulls it along the ground
and then gently switches
hands when he turns around.
And just lastly I want to
show a clip that illustrates
a kind of combination
of different responses.
So here first of all we've got an infant
playing with the corpse
and I think he's sort of
veering between fear and curiosity really.
Until it seems like curiosity
gets the better of him.
And so this is the dead infant's mother
and this is the live,
so this infant's mother.
And if you watch carefully you'll see that
that live infant's mother is also peering
at the body with curiosity.
But then she, in a moment,
she'll show what might be seen
as a sort of aversion to the corpse.
So watch this.
She doesn't really, she's
happy for her infant
to play with the corpse,
but she really doesn't
want to be touched by it.
So having said that, this
was really the only time
when we saw any individual
respond in this way.
So far I've talked about dead
infant care in chimpanzees,
but this is something that is seen
very broadly among primates.
We have examples, for
example, from geladas,
mountain gorillas, orangutans, lemurs,
and some of it on a really huge scale.
So Sugiyama and his
colleagues, for example,
documented over 150 cases
of dead infant carrying
over 24 years of observation
on Japanese macaques.
And in each case really
the theme is the same.
The mothers continue to
show maternal behavior
toward their dead infants.
And furthermore the behavior
isn't restricted to primates.
So other mammals have
been seen to care for
and to transport dead infants.
So dolphins and whales, for
example, carry dead calves.
Dingos and elephants stay
with their deceased young.
Or this giraffe here from
Fred Bercovitch's observations
remains with and is sort of nudging
her dead calf in this picture.
So and the behavior itself
is generally explained
in terms of the persistence of this
extremely strong mother-infant
bond in these species.
It's particularly strong in mammals
where the mother really
invests a huge amount
into each of her offspring.
And then if we also add
in non-infant deaths,
so all their individuals,
thereto we have some of the
same responses that we see
for infant, that we saw for infants.
So caretaking like
grooming, that inspection
and attendance by the body,
but also things that indicate
maybe more negative or sort of conflicted
psychological states such as alarm calling
or aggression and even cannibalism
and sexual behavior in some cases.
And I think there are some more kind of
nuanced response classes as well,
but the majority really do,
the majority which are reported
in this large collection of papers
which I'm going to make use of next,
can be classed into one or other
of these kind of broad categories.
So then on the next slide
I'm going to try to show you
graphically how these different responses
are distributed among the
mammalian orders and species
that we saw at the beginning.
So for example, in chimpanzees,
other authors have reported
aggression towards corpses
including those of infants
and even cannibalism.
And then in other species as well,
we see quite a sort of
broad spectrum of responses
from caretaking to sexual behavior.
But I should say that, so
some of these descriptions
I think are more complete than others
and obviously for some
orders we have information
on the treatment only of dead infants,
but not of dead adults or vice versa.
So I think this I maybe
best seen as really
just a snapshot of our current knowledge,
very much just an emerging picture.
But it does mean that, I
think that we can say that
at least these responses are present
in these different orders and species.
So then the important question
of what drives these different responses,
what might determine
when individuals respond
with caretaking and when
with aggression or alarm?
And several people here have discussed
interesting potential
ideas, so for example,
a death where the cause is clear.
So let's say a predator attack,
may lead to less say, alarm calling
than a case where the cause is unclear,
so like an opaque illness for example.
Then state of decomposition.
So how much like alive
animal the corpse looks.
It may be that less decomposed corpses
elicit more kind of normal
or stronger reactions.
Then the deceased's social status,
so an alpha male, a dead
alpha male would generate
more interest than a more peripheral male.
Or an infant that's not yet
fully socially integrated.
Also the deceased's social
relationship to the individual.
So a mother will respond,
probably will respond
differently to her own dead offspring
than to an unrelated group mate.
Also, Christophe Boesch
interestingly suggests
that groups that live in
high predation habitats
have more frequent
encounters with and therefore
a more kind of sophisticated
knowledge of death.
While in a sort of similar vein
Katie Cronin's team suggests
that a chimpanzee mother
with a dead infant
is actively seeking sensory
information on the corpse
which may inform her future behavior
should another one of her infants die.
So we might be seeing not
only these kinds of proximate
body cue and relationship quality effect,
but also learning about
death in determining
what responses we see.
But perhaps there's also
slightly different way of looking
at this if we wanted to
split things up by sort of
underlying psychological states.
So there are some reactions
that might fall under
sort of normal interactions
and those might suggest
that there's a lack of understanding
that the state of that
individual has changed.
Although I think even that's not
entirely clear in all cases.
But at some point we begin
to see behaviors that suggest
that such recognition
has indeed taken place.
And I think stemming from this recognition
we may find things like curiosity,
curious exploration of the
body and we may find fear,
so fearful responses like alarm calling.
But essentially I think
that what we might be seeing
is that at the intersection
of these things
is a recognition by the individual
that something's not right.
So, even though this
corpse may look normal,
it doesn't act normal when
I try to play with it.
It doesn't join in when I
hit it, it doesn't respond.
So in a way the corpse
violates expectations
as Andre Goncalves calls it.
To which you might respond
with curiosity or fear.
Or some combination of these two.
But if that is the case,
then this can in turn
tell us about what those expectations are
that non-human animals have.
And that comes back to those questions
that I raised at the very
beginning for the baboon.
Do they know the difference between
animate and inanimate things?
What cues do they use to tell
the difference between things
that are alive and things
that aren't alive and so on.
And of course these are some
of the exact same questions
that developmental psychologists
are asking and studying.
Children's understanding
of animosity and death.
And it also links to the motivation behind
comparative thanatology,
this recently emerged field,
that seeks evolutionary roots
to death related behavioral
and psychological phenomena.
So the idea is that by using information
from species that are both
closely and distantly related
to humans we can gain insight
into the evolutionary origins
of our own responses to the dead.
So and then returning to grief,
although I think the adaptive value
of grief is unclear to us.
In other words it's not entirely clear
what the function of grief is.
It could be a signal to
attract support from others
or simply it could be just a
by-product of the processes
that maintain those strong
social bonds in the first place.
And they linger even once that
individual has passed away,
one of the individuals has passed away.
But having said that,
there are among non-humans
quantifiable behavioral
and hormonal responses
that accompany the loss of an individual
with a close social bond.
So we see loss of appetite, loss of sleep,
withdrawal from the social group,
things like lethargy, and
even elevated stress hormones.
And so given all of this,
I think I agree with
Barbara King's perspective
here that it's possible
to decouple grief from
the awareness of death.
So you don't have to know what death is
in order to be able to grieve.
And then finally, that
brings us to this last point,
which is that managing grief is something
that we perhaps ought to
bear in mind explicitly
when devising management plans
for dying zoo individuals or even pets.
So in zoos dying animals
are often separated
from their normal social groups
and pets that are about to be euthanized
are also often separated
from their companions.
But this can lead to
extended periods of searching
and distress in those
companions that get left behind.
So alternatives to these practices
might be seen as more humane.
So this here is the chimpanzee, Pansy,
who was allowed to die in the
company of her social group
at the Scotland zoo and
Jim Anderson and colleagues
who've studied that particular case
argue that this allowed
those others in the group
that remained behind to gain a sense
of the fact that Pansy wasn't coming back.
So if we consider the
welfare of the animals
that stay behind then I
think it may be better
to allow death not to happen
kind of removed in space
and out of sight, but
actually in the presence
of the others with whom that individual
shares a close social bond.
And that might prevent extended distress
in these close affiliates
and also allow animals
to learn about the dying process
and about the finality of death.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks very much for the opportunity
to come and talk with you today.
I'm gonna speak about
our work on how crows
and other birds recognize
and respond to their dead.
The message is fairly simple.
From what we know at this point,
I think that it mainly is an opportunity
for them to learn about sources of death
and places to avoid and perhaps
other objects in the environment to avoid.
So I see it as a real arena for learning.
Before I get into the crows,
I wanted to step back to the
mammals for just a second
and relate quite an
interesting observation
I had in Yellowstone National Park
about four years ago to this day.
And at this point we were
with a group of students
looking at a wolf kill trying
to assess the landscape
that might've contributed to this death.
And it was an old female that had died,
she'd been killed about two weeks earlier.
And the death scene was one
of a large cleft boulder.
The female had backed into that,
it was a bison that had been
killed by a pack of wolves.
And we were measuring the aspects
of the terrain and the situation.
There was a lot of still
bloodstained on the rock
and the bones of the dead
female bison on the ground.
And as we were busying ourselves,
we heard a roar of hooves
come over the ridge
and a whole herd of
about three dozen bison
displaced us from that scene.
And we felt pretty bad
for having been there
and interrupted this situation.
But the thing that was impressive
was that these bison
after they pushed us away,
they all smelled the
bones much as we heard
with other mammals and
then each one individually
walked through this cleft in the rock,
right where the female had been killed,
and passed through and
then went on their way.
They were there for
about an hour in total.
And that's very different than we see
with the response to when
a crow finds a dead animal.
So what you see in this video
are the responses of crows
to finding a dead bird that
we placed on the ground
right below that telephone pole.
They come in, they're
very noisy, they gather.
And they might last for 15 or 20 minutes
before they move on out of the area.
And this is a widespread
response that's been seen
in other members of this
family, the Corvidae,
that includes things like magpies,
which have been seen to even bring
tufts of grass into a dead magpie.
Or a scrub jays.
There's been a lot of work on scrub jays
just north of us here.
And also ravens gathering around the dead.
So let me introduce you to
this family of birds briefly.
They're birds that are
familiar to most of us.
They live close by with us.
They include the ravens and crows,
magpies, jays, nutcrackers.
And they live around the world
in all the continents except Antarctica.
And almost all of these species have had
some sort of interaction as I described
with the crows to finding the dead.
So some aspects of this group.
They're long lived.
They're typically social.
They have long lasting
partnerships with their mates
and sometimes extended family groups.
They have rather large
brains for their body size.
On this graph, these show the
average relationships between
body size on the x-axis and
brain size on the y-axis.
For things like fish, and
here's the average bird line.
And then you'll see that the
dots for the various corvids
are well above the bird line,
more on the mammal line.
And even some like the
American crow that I study,
right on the primate line.
So these are really more
like small flying monkeys
than they are birds.
Their brains are quite complex.
We know now in the last several decades
that they include places in the brain
that are analogous and
also homologous to ours.
For example the hippocampus
is a homologous structure.
And the amygdala is at least
an analogous structure.
They have a large forebrain,
all this area here.
There's a striatum, but a large forebrain
where more complex sorts
of sensory information
might be combined and considered.
And they have important connections
between the forebrain and the thalamus
back up to the forebrain
that allows these animals
to reconsider actions and shape them
before they act upon
those, that information.
So the typical response is
to get some information in,
maybe from the eye, process
it in the forebrain,
and send a response down the spinal cord
to the muscles to do something.
But they don't have to always do that
because of a connection
here that allows that
information to go back to the
forebrain and be adjusted.
That's how they, for example,
learn different vocalizations.
So with an animal like that, long lived,
social and quite cognitively nimble,
there are many reasons why
they might attend their dead
as we discussed just
with Dora's presentation.
So they may be looking
at a social opportunity,
a vacant territory, a
potential mate, for example.
They may be looking to learn about danger.
They may be looking at
other aspects of that scene
to learn what caused the death,
what sort of expectation in the future
that area may hold for
danger and things like that.
They may also be grieving and mourning
a loss to member of their family.
Or as I said, since these
animals mate for life,
they might've been with
this same individual
that's dead now for 20 or 30 years
and might have a profound relationship
and interaction with that
animal after it's lost.
So we have tried to investigate
this response by doing experiments.
And what we do is we basically prepare
taxidermy mounts of individual crows
and have them in kind of a dead status
and then we place those
out and see the response
of wild birds to those mounts.
And this is a general
description based on what we do.
There's some sort of a conditioning phase
where we get animals used
to coming to an area.
Then we present them with some stimulus.
That could be a dead crow
or a hawk for example,
just to see the response.
And then we measure their response
after they've encountered that.
And during this time we've
been feeding them at a spot
so we know they reliably come in,
they're using that spot to gain food.
And we can look for a
change in their behavior.
Maybe how long it takes for
them to approach that food
after they've seen a dead bird there.
So what we found, and
this is work I should say
that my Ph.D. student, Kaeli Swift,
and I have been engaged in
and Kaeli's continuing this work now,
but these are some of the early findings
that she discovered.
First off in terms of
how many gatherings occur
around these dead crows,
about 60% of all the crows
we put out had a large
mob form around them.
And that's similar to what you would see
if a hawk was present,
which is a known danger.
And it's not as often as you would see
if a hawk had a dead crow
in its grip for example.
That's almost always elicits
this sort of response.
So from this comparing to
more controlled situations
where just a person is there feeding
or just food is provided,
suggests that this is
some sort of response to danger for sure.
And we know that the individuals
are learning something
about being in this dangerous place
because their approach to
the food is quite different
after a danger has been
seen versus not been seen.
So here you just see the amount of time
pre and post exposure to a stimulus.
In this case the stimulus
is just food or a person,
nothing dangerous, no difference.
And if the stimulus is
a hawk or a dead crow,
much longer time to approach
that food after seeing that.
And this kind of narrows that response
'cause actually in some
cases the birds refused
to come down to food in a
place they had seen a dead crow
for up to six to eight weeks.
And this is different also depending upon
whether it's a crow or
a pigeon that they see,
so they're very sensitive
to the type of stimulus.
They avoid places after
seeing a dead crow,
even though they had been
feeding there before.
But if a dead pigeon is placed there,
there's no real response, no difference.
And also crows do this
and not all birds do this.
So we just controlled this
by looking at the response
of pigeons as well as crows
to this sort of presentation.
And when pigeons see a
place they've been fed at
that now has a dead pigeon at it,
they continue to feed there afterwards
like nothing had happened.
I suspect turkeys, we've been
seeing some turkey videos
of turkeys walking around a dead cat today
and I suspect they act like
pigeons in this respect.
But crows clearly increase their hesitancy
to approach a spot after they've
seen a dead animal there.
And this is a pretty
nuanced response as well.
So what we see in this
graph is that the response
to an adult crow that's
dead versus a juvenile crow
that's dead over here is different.
And that's especially different
during the breeding season.
So when you find a dead juvenile crow
in the breeding season, which
is a fairly common response,
lot of young birds die, birds,
the adult crows and
other crows in the area
don't pay much attention to that.
They only scold and form a
mob about a third of the time.
Likewise during the breeding season
if an adult is found, scolding
and mobbing is not as common
as it is during the non-breeding season.
So this sort of nuanced
response to me suggests
that this sort of behavior is triggered
more by an ecological or more of a social
or ecological factor than
it is perhaps something
like grieving or mourning
the loss of this individual.
In fact, I would expect the exact opposite
if they were really
considering, for example,
a lost young bird of their own,
their sibling or their
offspring or their mate,
you would expect those responses
to be especially strong
during the breeding season, for example,
and especially strong among adult birds.
So we have tried to
understand where in the brain
the crow is processing this information.
And using that to help
explain a little bit more
about why they're doing
this sort of thing.
And let me explain our procedure to you
a little bit here in this slide.
We're doing PET imaging of live crows
as they view various sorts
of dangerous stimuli.
A hawk, a person that
had just captured them
or a person holding a
dead crow for example.
And what we do, shown up here at the top,
is we capture our birds in the wild.
We wear a mask when we capture them
so that they learn a particular face
associated with that dangerous experience
being captured in the wild.
We capture them with a net
gun that goes off with a blast
and pins them to the ground,
it's a pretty scary thing for a bird.
And we don't want them
to associate that with us
when we see them later and
we want to be able to have
anybody take on the role
of that dangerous person
by putting on this mask.
So we wear a mask when we catch them.
We then bring the birds into captivity
and care for them
wearing a different mask.
So we have one person that's
good here caring for the birds
and one person that's bad
that has captured the bird.
And we keep the birds for about a month.
And during this time we bring
them into a smaller cage
shown in the middle diagram here
where they are acclimated overnight
and then the next morning we
perform a procedure upon them.
And that procedure is
simply to catch the bird
out of the cage, inject
it with a glucose mimic
that we use as a tracer to
indicate where synaptic activity,
where nerve cells are
actively communicating
with one another and we then
put them back in that cage
after they've been given the
shot of glucose in their belly.
And then we show them something.
We let them while they're
awake look out and observe
perhaps just a person in the
room that they never seen.
They could observe the
person that caught them
or the person that cared for them
or a person holding a dead crow
or a hawk or nothing at all.
And then during that 20 minutes or so
we continue to let them
see that person on and off.
And we then anesthetize them.
And this tracer with the PET
imaging allows us to basically
step back in time while
they're anesthetized
and see where in the brain
that tracer has accumulated
during the time when they
were actually looking
at that stimulus we gave them.
So this way we can keep
them still, get a nice image
and see what's going on in their brain.
Then wake them up, let 'em rest for a day.
Let the tracer, the
radioactive tracer clear
and they can be released back to the wild.
So for example, here's
what a crow would see
if it was sitting in our cage metabolizing
that glucose we gave it and
looking out and seeing a person
it had never seen before
holding a dead crow.
The images we get of
their brain are striking.
They show relative activity
by how bright the areas are here.
This is the glucose fluorescing
basically in the tomography.
And what you see here are bright
spots on either hemisphere
of the brain which are the
entopallium of the bird,
that's the visual processing
center of a bird's brain
assessing information coming
from the two eyes here.
I'm gonna show you a set of graphs
that looks somewhat like this figures
that basically show MRIs in
gray to show you the structure
of the bird's brain and
then the red areas indicate
what parts of the brain
were most activated
in a given set of birds that saw one thing
versus a set of birds that
saw something quite different.
And in this case, this
shows the part of the brain,
and this is the front
part of the bird's brain,
that's activated when they
saw a person in the room
versus nobody else in the room.
So any kind of person in this case.
There's a lot of higher order processing
occurring in the forebrain of these birds
as they consider that person
and also in the striatum
as they possibly are making
connections between that person
and something that it had previously done.
Now if we look at them
in response to basically
how they see particular people,
what we have on the top panel here
is the response of birds
when they looked out
and they saw the person that
had previously captured them,
so a dangerous person.
And they're recalling at this point
something about that person.
They already know that he was dangerous
and now what we see activated most clearly
in addition to that frontal area
that I showed previously
is their amygdala.
So they're basically responding
like other vertebrates do
with a strong response
on the right hemisphere
of their brain, in the
amygdala region that indicates
they're responding to a known danger,
a learned danger I should say.
In contrast when they see a person
that they've never seen before
and they're learning about
that person's behavior
because it's holding a dead crow,
what is activated most strongly
is the hippocampus in the bird.
So what we interpret is going on here
is that these birds are
acquiring information,
they're learning about
this dangerous person
by its association with a
dead crow, and in this case,
they're recalling
something already learned.
We know something about the
way information proceeds
from the eyes up to the bird's brain.
And I just show you this
diagram to point out
the complexity with which
this information travels
from the retina up
through the basal ganglia
and into the forebrain.
And it's a rather simple picture actually
when they're looking at a
person that they've learned
to be threatening as
compared to the situation
when they're first
assessing somebody that's
potentially dangerous by, in
fact, holding this dead crow.
So here the hippocampus is
involved as well as the forebrain
and the visual processing centers.
And in this case it's mainly the forebrain
and the visual processing
centers interacting.
So all of these field experiments
and laboratory experiments
basically point me to one conclusion.
When we show a crow a dead crow
that's not a familiar individual,
that they're responding and
learning about that situation.
Perhaps the person associated with it
or the place associated with that death.
Quite clear I think in this respect to me.
But what else could we be missing?
And to me this is the more
interesting part of the work
that we basically, I can
only tell you, I don't know.
But I hope to find out at some point.
But this is a pair of ravens
interacting with one another.
They form very close relationships.
And surely I would guess,
we would see differences
in the brain activity of a
bird after it had lost its mate
than if it just encounters a dead bird
that it doesn't know personally.
But we haven't done that experiment.
It's something that could be done,
but ethically is difficult to do.
There are other things
that suggest there may be
a lot more going on than
just learning about a site.
And these are more anecdotal observations.
I mentioned earlier that when
magpies come into their dead,
they've been observed to carry grass.
And maybe that's just the nesting material
that they were carrying
when they encountered that
or maybe it was something more purposeful.
So for example, in crows
this picture shows one
that was found that was
surrounded by these sticks.
There were no trees around,
there was nothing where
these sticks could've just
been there incidentally.
Maybe a human put them
there or perhaps the crow
had come in and put those
sticks around this dead crow.
We don't know, but have
several observations
like this from people.
And then finally, just a week ago,
a woman sent me this image which she took
on the Michigan State University campus.
And what you see here is a crow
that is looking at a dead crow.
The dead crow is only recently died.
The woman suggested it might've hit
a window or something by the looks of it.
And this bird flew in, totally silent,
brought this piece of tinfoil in its bill
and set it down in front of the dead crow.
And it stood there for
20 minutes watching this.
I have no idea if these are a mated pair
or if again, this was anything
other than incidental,
but it's curious to me
that they didn't scold,
this bird didn't scold and
didn't attract a crowd in
like we regularly see.
So I think there's much more
going on here than we know
and it will take much more
sophisticated experiments
to get at them, which hopefully
we'll do in the future.
With that I would thank you
very much for your attention.
(audience applauding)
- So I'm also very grateful
for this invitation.
I think, I haven't been this excited
about death for a long time.
(audience laughing)
So just to set the context
of my talk a little bit,
you'll remember when Dora
presented the baboon slides
and the various questions that
we might ask of those baboons
with respect to their
understanding of death.
What I'll be telling you
I think in part today
is that the answer to
many of those questions
with respect to children
at a fairly young age
is yes, that they have an understanding.
But then I'll go on to say more
about how that understanding
might be displaced or amplified
by the notions of afterlife
or religion that that particular
culture presents to them.
So that's the gist of the presentation.
Some acknowledgements here.
My good colleague, Rita Astuti,
whom you'll be hearing
more from this afternoon.
Marta Gimenez with whom I
did some research in Spain.
Three colleagues at the
University of Texas.
I'll mention them later
when I talk about some work in Vanuatu.
So, as I've said,
children probably acquire,
and certainly by the age of
seven or eight have acquired,
what we might think of as a
biological theory of death.
That's to say they seem
to understand that death
is a terminal point for all
mental and bodily processes.
And indeed children of this
age, seven, eight, nine,
it varies a little bit
from child to child,
also seem to understand
the universality of death,
that it applies to everybody,
that it's irreversible.
And it's also true that they understand
something of the mechanics of death.
That's to say that the body is a machine.
That there are various
parts, invisible parts,
lungs, heart and so forth,
which have to be coordinated,
and when those parts break down,
then death is inevitable
with various consequences.
At the same time, children will encounter
a religious account or
a supernatural account
and part of what I want to discuss
as I mentioned a moment ago,
is the relationship in the child's mind
between these two different accounts.
So in order to explore that question
of the relationship
between the two accounts,
we, that's to say myself
and Marta Gimenez,
tested children of five years of age,
sorry, seven years of age
and 11 years of age in Spain.
I mention Spain advisedly in some sense
because of course these
children were therefore
growing up in a particular
religious culture.
The children were not
just quizzed about their,
as it were, immediate or
biological conception of death,
but we tried to prompt their
religious conception as well.
And we did this therefore in the context
of two different stories.
One about the death of a grandparent
and at the end of the story,
the grandchild is visited by a doctor.
And the other also about
the death of a grandparent,
but in this story, the
grandchild who's lost
their grandparent is visited by a priest.
So I'll just show you those two stories.
As you can see toward the end here,
"The doctor came to talk to
Juan about what had happened.
And, "He said to Juan, 'Your
grandfather is dead now.'"
You can see that there
is no hint in this story
of an afterlife or there
are no religious cues.
The second story, the priest
story, is fairly similar,
thus to say death of a
grandparent who's been ill,
goes to the hospital.
But as you can see at
the end of the story,
Marta, the protagonist,
is visited by a priest
rather than by a doctor who
explains what has happened.
And puts to Marta the claim that,
"Your grandmother is now with God."
So each child listened
to both of these stories.
And after each story we would ask about
the functioning of various processes.
Sometimes we asked about
bodily processes, for example,
"Have his eyes stopped working?"
And sometimes we asked
about mental processes,
"Can he still see?"
And as in this case, we
tried to choose pairings,
that's to say where we would
focus in on a bodily organ
and an accompanying mental process.
We couldn't always do that,
but roughly speaking, that was our goal.
So ultimately the children
answered about 14 questions,
seven about functioning of the body,
seven about the functioning of the mind.
The children gave their reply.
They would either say this
process was continuing or not.
And then we would ask them
to offer an explanation
of why it had stopped or conversely,
why the process was continuing.
And we found that we could
allocate children's answers to
three different categories,
religious, biological,
and a more equivocal set of replies.
So let's just present the way in which
we scored children for
each of those categories.
So religious answers, well in this case,
the child would claim that
a given process continues,
so yes, he can still see.
And then they, when we'd
say, "Well, how is that?"
They would supply a religious explanation.
"In Heaven everything can
work even if she is dead."
"The soul keeps working," and so forth.
So you can see very clearly in these cases
references to religious notions,
heaven to soul and so forth.
Now if we turn to the biological answers,
here the child claims that
the process has stopped.
And as you can see,
they're pretty blunt
about why it's stopped.
"He's been eaten by worms, he has no body.
"He's just bones."
"If he's dead, nothing can work."
And then finally, no credit answers.
These were replies where the child either
didn't offer an explanation
or if they did so,
it didn't seem to fit in with the judgment
that they'd made about the
process working or not working.
So what I'm gonna do next is just show you
the replies for the seven-year-olds
and just to give you a heads up,
the biological answers are
black, I mean the bars are black.
The religious answers are white.
And in between you'll see some gray
for equivocal so to speak.
More than that, I'll show
you the extent to which
the child offers religious
replies or biological replies
or equivocal replies with respect
to those two story settings.
Remember the priest story
and the doctor story
and also within those two stories
for mental processes
versus bodily processes.
So here's as I say, an overview
of the seven-year-olds.
And you can see it's fairly black.
That's to say most of
the time the children
are giving biologically oriented answers.
And if you look at the left
hand side of the figure
where I've charted replies
for the doctor stories,
whether it be about the body or the mind,
you can see that biology is dominating.
But if you shift over to
the two right hand columns,
you see that religion is beginning
to get a look in so to speak.
More religious replies and the proportion
of biological answers is declining.
So in other words, when
you present the same child
or well, essentially the same child, yes,
a story with some religious cues,
they pick up on those cues
and they start to interpret
the death in a different context
or in a different fashion.
So that's the picture
for the seven-year-olds.
Now we can ask what we will,
might find with the older children,
with the 11-year-olds and the
extent to which biology might,
so to speak, consolidate
itself or religion might
consolidate itself or there might be
some competition between these two modes.
And here's what we find.
You can see that religion
is predominating,
especially when we've given the child
as you see in the two right hand columns,
those afterlife cues.
So if the priest is introduced,
whether the child is asked
about the body or the mind,
there's a lot of religious talk
in their replies and justifications.
So the next step that we took was to ask,
given that we had presented
each child with two stories,
to ask how consistent any
individual child might be
across those two stories and
indeed across essentially
the 28 questions that we had asked them.
So at one extreme, a given child might be
consistently biological in their answer.
They might assume that death
is terminal and that's that,
no matter what the process
and no matter what the story context.
Conversely they might be
consistently religious in their answers.
And finally, we could
imagine an individual child
who shifts their ground
depending on the story context
or indeed, on the particular process
that they're being invited to think about.
So you'll see in the next slide,
again these two age groups,
seven-year-olds and 11-year-olds,
but I'm gonna show you
the proportion of children
falling into these three categories.
So here are the findings.
So you can see that the seven-year-olds
as we might of suspected
from the earlier figure,
approach death from a predominantly
biological perspective.
On the other hand, if
you look at that red bar,
we do see some proportion,
about 30% of those seven-year-olds,
who are mixing it, who
go backwards and forward
so to speak between the
biological and religious.
And a small proportion who
are consistently religious.
Now if we turn to the 11-year-olds,
we might've imagined that the
consistently religious bar,
the white bar, would be the one showing
the most sharp increase between
the younger children
and the older children.
That's the not the case as you see.
What we do see is a decline in
consistently biological responding
and an increase in this
mixed pattern of responding
where the child depending
upon the particular question
we've asked is inclined to offer
a biological account
or a religious account.
More generally I would say and these data
are fitted into other data, it looks as if
children by the age of late
middle childhood so to speak,
have arrived at these two accounts.
They don't necessarily
think of the two accounts
as competitors with each other.
They think of them as
compatible with each other.
But it's also true and
this is going a little bit
beyond the data, but I
think it's very plausible,
that the starting point for young children
is the biological.
So they arrive at this biological account
of which as I said
earlier, by seven or eight
they realize is a universal account
and therefore applies to themselves.
And it may be that that's
the foundation ultimately,
this biological account for
their increasing appreciation
of the message that is offered
by religion so to speak.
Which after all in some sense presupposes
the biological account,
but then denies it,
which says death is not the end.
So there's a sense in which
from our point of view
we are seeing somewhat
paradoxical conceptual development
here where conclusions that
the child has arrived at
from a relatively objective point of view
are going to put aside
or set aside in part
by virtue of religious teaching.
So there's a quick summary of
what I've just reported to you
and as I've emphasized,
as children get older,
this mixed stance is
the one that dominates.
I'm going to give you a very
quick taste of Rita's talk
by showing you a map of Madagascar.
That's all I'm going to do.
I'm going to show you a
picture of her field site.
She will tell you what happens
when you go to Madagascar
and you repeat this kind of interview
with children and with adults.
Bearing in mind that in Madagascar,
we're not talking about
a Christian culture,
we're talking about a
culture which believes in
the existence of the ancestors.
So I'm gonna move on quickly
instead to Tanna, Vanuatu.
As you can see off the
east coast of Australia.
And in particular this island of Tanna
is one where my colleagues in Austin
led by Christine Legare have been doing
these kinds of interviews with children
and indeed with adults in Tanna.
Okay.
They took essentially the design study,
the study design that I described
a moment ago to Vanuatu.
But they also tested
adults in Austin, Texas.
And the basic question
was the extent to which
we would find a distinctive pattern,
particularly in Vanuatu or
whether we would replicate
the basic pattern we'd seen in Spain.
One, it seems like a
minor mathological point,
but I think it's of greater significance.
In this particular study, each participant
was only presented with one
story, not with two stories.
So you could argue looking
back at the results
we got in Spain that
the reason why children
showed this duality, this
co-existence of two accounts,
was precisely because the two
children had been presented
with two different narratives about death.
In this study then, each
participant only got one story
and we'll see if nonetheless,
we get this pattern of mixed responding.
So that's the basic question.
And I'm going to show you
now the results that we got
when we presented a story
with afterlife cues,
similar to the one that
I mentioned a moment ago
with respect to Madrid and Spain,
but with certain cultural
adjustments given,
given the culture.
The two cultures I should say.
So here are the findings.
Pretty straightforward as you can see,
in both places we see that
the consistently biological
is in the minority.
In both places we do see some individuals
who offer consistently
religious responding.
But the very clear
result is this prevalence
of a mixed stance or mixed responding
both in the United States and in Vanuatu.
So that leads me to then
some overall conclusions.
It looks as if from our data
and actually that's echoed
not just in Spain, but also in Madagascar,
that young children don't
really pay much heed
to the religious narrative which is
available in their culture.
They come to an understanding
of death in biological terms.
And more probing interviews than those
I've presented to you today suggest
as I mentioned earlier, that
this is part of a theory
in the sense that the children also can
invoke various unobservable bodily organs
and realize that the body is coherent
or has to work coherently
for life to continue.
And when life stops,
you see a termination of most processes.
So children have established that notion
by around seven or eight years of age.
As that theory or account is consolidated
it seems as if they become more receptive
to the existing theological, supernatural
or religious account that
exists in their culture.
And that, having said that, it's not as if
that religious stance leads
them to forget or suppress
what they know about biology.
So what you see among
large numbers of people
in all of these populations is a tendency
to oscillate between the two accounts.
And to the best of our knowledge,
these two accounts are not perceived to be
in conflict with one another.
And I think Rita will present you
with more ethnographic
evidence this afternoon
that indeed people move rather smoothly
from one account to the other.
Now let me just say one or two words
about the broader implications then
of these developmental findings
for more comparative
approach that we will be
reviewing in the course of today.
So these developmental
findings may or may not
point to what happened in
the course of human history.
And they may or may not point to ideas
that we can bring to
primatology in particular.
Could it be that primates have some
minimal biological understanding
and should we assume that
the religious notion of course,
would ultimately in the human species
build on that biological notion.
Which is already hinted
at in our close cousins.
Let me stop there, thank you.
(audience applauding)
(light instrumental music)